when we look at all of the data that we
now have when we look at the several
thousand descriptions that people have
of the Enlightenment experiences when we
look at over two hundred and fifty brain
scans that we've done of people engaged
in different types of prayer and
meditation practices I think one of the
things that we can ultimately distill
out of this on a very practical level is
how do we actually help people down
their own path to enlightenment what are
the what are the steps that people need
to think about taking so that they can
find their own path I think one of the
important aspects of all of this is that
on one hand we can talk about this in
generalities there are certain basic
elements there are certain basic
approaches that people can take certain
basic aspects of the experience that
people are going to have but it
ultimately is also a unique phenomenon
and for each person part of what we need
to try to encourage them to do is to
find their own pathway to find that own
uniqueness that makes it an experience
that's meaningful for them so we start
to think about the actual steps that
people take we've been able to to define
that into the five different specific
steps that we think are relevant for
this process the first step we usually
talk about is the desire to make this
kind of change in your life did the
desire to have enlightenment now on one
hand that may sound like a silly thing
to say because on one hand why wouldn't
everybody want to have it and to some
degree that's true I mean I think almost
if you went up to anybody on the street
and say hey would you like to have the
most incredible experience you could
ever have change your life change the
way you think about the world and you're
happy for the rest of your life I think
most people would say yeah sure that
sounds great sign me up but the bottom
line is is that they are difficult
experiences to get to they're certainly
not impossible but they are difficult
and they are a little scary when you
think about it because it's rearranging
the normal way you've thought about the
world so up to up till now which for the
most part has worked for you and when
you think about how our brain works our
brain usually doesn't like change very
much so when you say well we're going to
radically change your brain your brain
is thinking wait a minute you know
things are going pretty okay so far I
don't really want to have these kinds of
big changes going on in my life so I
think part of the whole process to start
with is
yes you know I really would like to have
this kind of an experience I'd like to
change I'd like to experience something
that's different than the way I have
normally thought about things one of the
exercises that we often ask people to do
is to go home to take out a piece of
paper and just sit at the table or sit
at your desk take a few deep breaths get
yourself into a nice relaxed state and
what we what we suggest is that you
write down a couple of reasons why you
would like to have an Enlightenment
experience maybe write down two or three
reasons why you would like to feel this
enlightenment experience and another
related exercise is to sit down and
write down what you think enlightenment
means to you what is it that you are
thinking about what what is it that you
would ultimately like to achieve through
this type of process these can be very
good ways of beginning to get the mind
open and engaged in the process it helps
the brain to say okay yes this is
something that I really want this is
what I think it is this is what I'm
working towards and this is what begins
us down that path towards enlightenment
the next step that we usually talk about
is the idea of preparing for this
experience and what we mean by that is
not only do you have to desire it but
you have to start to get ready to do
this kind of practice do the kinds of
practices you may need to do get
yourself ready for this kind of an
experience part of what we talked about
in this context are relaxation
techniques because as you start to go
down this path sometimes it can be scary
sometimes there's a lot of different
issues that come up for a person it can
raise a lot of problems for the person
and so being prepared being ready
thinking it through a little bit trying
to get yourself into a kind of mood
that's ready for this kind of an
experience becomes very important very
helpful relaxation exercises that can be
as simple as just sitting there quietly
and taking deep breaths over a period of
several minutes to five minutes or so
there are many different kinds of mantra
based meditation practices where you can
start to focus on a particular image or
a phrase that you can say over and over
again those are the kinds of practices
that people can do another very popular
one is progressive muscle relaxation
where you tense and then relax each of
the muscle groups starting with your the
top of your head and your neck your body
your are
arms your legs and you just as you
tighten them very intensely and then
release them that starts to induce a
greater greater feeling of relaxation so
all of these any of these can work very
well for the individual again each
person has to kind of come up with the
ones that work best for them that they
like that they feel good with and this
is part of that process of what prepares
them for the experience of enlightenment
now the third step to me is really the
critical one in many ways and the one
that that people really have to think
about what makes it kind of most unique
for them and that has to do with the
particular practice rituals the process
itself that will lead them down that
path now this is where it does become
highly individualized because some
people may like to do prayer and some
people may like to walk around some
people may take drugs
some people may do transcranial magnetic
stimulation of the brain there are many
different approaches that people can
take but trying to find the one or ones
that work best for you that is that
individualized approach that will help
to lead you down that path most
effectively sometimes you have to try
different things you know sometimes
people I have so many people come up to
me and say well you know I tried this
meditation and it didn't do very much
for me but boy once I started to do this
other practice it really it was amazing
sometimes people try all different kinds
of meditation practices and they say I
don't know what's wrong with me it's not
working for me
I say well maybe you know you need to
think about a different kind of practice
or a different kind of ritual but part
of it is something that you can kind of
keep coming back to that you can utilize
one of the key elements is frequently at
some type of rhythmic process and that's
why we talk about rituals and whether
that rhythmicity is part of meditation
singing creativity you know whatever it
is just thought processes challenging
yourself with different questions which
is part of what I did in my own in my
own pathway these are the kinds of
things that really helped bring a person
down their own personal path the fourth
step is ultimately this kind of feeling
of letting it all go this feeling of
surrendering to the experience itself to
say that is is simple to actually let
that happen in a profound way is not
always the easiest thing
for an individual sometimes it has to be
that you kind of keep challenging and
revving and revving up the brain to such
an extent that when you finally do say
you know what okay I'm just going to let
this happen now that's what really just
kind of pulls the rug out from under the
whole process and that very sudden
change in the way your brain goes
through the whole process that feeling
of surrender radically changes the way
your brain works at that particular
moment one of the areas of our brain
that seems to be particularly involved
in this whole process of the rituals and
the feeling of surrender is our frontal
lobe located behind the far head and
what we have found is is that during
practices like meditation or prayer that
frontal lobe activity gets ramped up to
a very very high level but then when you
have this feeling of surrender it drops
down to a very low level in fact since
the frontal lobe is involved in helping
us do purposeful things when we
ultimately give our purposefulness over
to the process that frontal lobe
activity starts to decrease very
substantially and part of what we're
determining here is that it's not just
being high and being low it's the the
difference itself it's the change from
that peak to that very low level that
really rearranges the way the brain
works and sets up that very powerful
experience if you think about flying in
an airplane when you're on the ground
you don't feel very much and when you're
up in the air you don't feel very much
even though you're going four or five
hundred miles an hour but it's the
take-off or the landing where you really
feel the change occurring and that's
kind of what's going on in the brain
it's not being in one state or the other
it's the change that occurs that really
sets up the dramatic experience that
people can have and that drop of
activity from that very high level in
the frontal lobe to the very low level
in the frontal lobe is I think a very
important driving force of these
biologically behind the aspect of that
experience but that feeling of surrender
and giving oneself over to the
experience is a very critical element
down this process and then the last step
is really what we talked about is
reflecting on what this experience is
for you and what that really means is
that it's not just enough to have the
experience but how you then incorporate
it back into
your thought processes your beliefs your
experiences of the world the ways in
which you you think about the world and
and being able to come back and reflect
on that whether it's just throw up
thought processes or practice like
meditation this is this is a critical
element because it's what ultimately
brings that experience into your life
and makes it real for you and makes it
something that changes the way you think
about the world for the rest of your
life so that that ability to reflect is
very very critical and part of this
process can also be that people can have
more of the the smally enlightenment
experiences these sort of little mini
epiphanies that as they kind of build up
and as you keep bringing them back into
your life that can set you up also for
that very big enlightenment experience
as well so so going down all these
different paths to kind of keep coming
back to them to keep experiencing them
and keep working on it that to me is
probably the most effective way of
trying to get to the enlightenment
experience of course the bottom line is
is that I can never guarantee to anyone
that you're going to have enlightenment
there is no button to push that just
suddenly and magically transforms your
brain or gives you that experience and
again if we look at our survey some
people went through many many years of
meditation before they had their
experience some people that happened
while they were walking down the street
so we never really know how or when it's
going to happen but these steps I think
at least for people who want to try to
pursue that path and work towards it
that can be a very those five steps can
be a very important way in a very
powerful way of helping to get to that
experience of enlightenment there's a
very large amount of data including data
from our survey that talk about the the
downstream effects of all of this when
we asked people who had these
experiences in our survey about how it
changed their life overwhelmingly these
were positive experiences 95 percent of
people basically had something positive
to say about this experience and it
could and it inundated almost every
aspect of their life so when we asked
them did it improve your relationships
with people they said yes it did because
they felt more compassionate more loved
more open with the people that they were
interacting with when we asked them
about their sense of meaning and
purpose in life they all said yes we
have more great are greater sense of
meaning and purpose in life I know what
I need to do I know why we're here I
understand it I get it you know and now
I know what I need to do in my life and
it puts their job in perspective it puts
all the things that they know how they
interact with their family and
perspective so those are changes that
are very very important when we ask
people about their psychological and
physical health they almost all say yes
it was improved they felt reductions in
the stresses that they faced and their
and their everyday life they don't think
about stress the same way they don't
think about all the things that they
were worried about that stress them out
in the same way you know obviously if
you go down the path towards the
Buddhist perspective of enlightenment
the whole point of enlightenment is to
end suffering and to a large extent
that's borne out in the the way people
describe what these experiences do for
them that it reduces their sense of
distress their sense of anxiety their
sense of depression it helps to improve
all of those issues that people deal
with and even their physical health they
felt better overall when we ask people
about their fear of death people no
longer fear death in the same way that
we typically do so that seems to be
something that people experience as an
improvement from these experiences and
then ultimately when we ask people about
their religious and spiritual beliefs
again almost uniformly almost everyone
says that they did that those
experiences were also improved now
interestingly more people said that
their spirituality was improved than
their religiousness was improved so
these experiences tend to be considered
to be more spiritual than religious but
still there was a substantial chunk of
people who said that they felt that
their religious beliefs were also
improved and I think it probably comes
down a little bit to the nature of the
experience if somebody feels as part of
their enlightenment experience that they
have now intimately connected to God and
maybe that's based on their their
Catholic tradition for example or their
Jewish tradition then then they feel
like that has been an experience which
is deep in their religious beliefs
themselves but for a lot of people they
have this experience and it almost seems
to blow away the religious beliefs or at
least the religious doctrines and they
feel that that the religion itself is
sort of too limited in terms of helping
them to experience and explain
what that feeling was when they feel
that experience of enlightenment so
almost everybody feels more spiritual
but many people also feel more religious
and the bottom line is is that almost
regardless of what aspect of a person's
life you're talking about these
experiences change it dramatically
change it for the better
and clearly change the brain itself as
well so we see all of these kinds of
changes reflected in the person after
they have this kind of experience